tonight there is nothing in the pipeline
from Russia Today Russia's state-owned
gas producer gas problem announced a
complete halt to the float of natural
gas through that key nordstream one
pipeline to Germany the company saying
that it has discovered leaks in a
turbine
now the route was temporarily closed
this week for what Russia called
maintenance work now Russia says more
work needs to be done Germany is Reliant
still reliant on Russian natural gas and
accuses Moscow of cutting deliveries to
retaliate for Western economics
sanctions
earlier I spoke to DW's Benjamin Alvarez
Gruber here in Berlin and I asked him
what more we know about Guest prom's
announcement basically turning off the
taps that's right after this maintenance
it was supposed to end today but
according it to gasprom State owns um
Russia's state-owned Energy company this
was this oil leak at the compressor
station meaning that it will not be able
to keep sending guests through this
Pipeline and it can still not say how
long this will take the maintenance it's
something that we've heard over the past
weeks and months that it's pretty
difficult for them to say when this
alleged oil leak will be solved and when
Russia will again be able to send gas
through this pipeline so what kind of
reaction if any are we hearing tonight
from Germany or the European Union
there have been several reactions
already one of them is Germany's economy
Ministry they said that this once again
underlines and shows that Russia is not
a reliable partner that is not abiding
to the contract to send to gas from
Russia to Germany we also had um one of
the chairs of the bundesla of the German
parliament's foreign affairs committee
saying that this is part of Russia's
psychological War and the European
commission also condemning this measure
so it shows that there's a definite lack
of trust between Russia and between
Germany
Nord stream flows halted for three days
earlier this week are the effects are
they already being felt
this takes a time also when Russia says
that there will be an amount of gas that
it will send to Germany those occult the
nominations a number that then is
processed by authorities here it's not
possible to say how long this will last
but what German authorities have said
well the economy Ministry has said that
Germany is now definitely better
prepared than it was a few months ago in
saying that the reserves of gas that
Germany now has are at around 83 84
percent so definitely better prepared
than it was a few months ago but it
shows that there's a there's no trust at
all a few months when there was this
annual maintenance by Russia and it says
that it will send reduced flow to
Germany with this gas it is not only
going to Germany but to other European
countries as well it was indeed a brief
relief but as there is no trust there
have been issues over over turbines
there was a turbine there was in Canada
under the sanctions European sanctions
and they were sent to Germany so there
is definitely no no trust between them
with economy Minister robertabek also
saying that Russia is using energy as a
weapon and calling it a political
maintenance of what he said previously
about Russia saying that there are these
problems with the turbine and therefore
it cannot deliver gas to Germany DW's
Benjamin Alvarez grouper with the latest
tonight here in Berlin Benjamin thank
you
Finance ministers from the G7 group of
Industrial Alliance Nations have pledged
to impose a price cap on Russian oil
they want to limit Russia's revenues and
its ability to fund the war in Ukraine
here's German Finance Minister Christian
Lindner
this price cap on Russian oil exports is
designed to reduce Putin's revenues to
close a major source of funding for this
war of aggression at the same time we
want to contain increases in global
Energy prices which will minimize
inflation globally
all right we want to pull in now
Anastasia fedig she is assistant
professor of Finance at the half School
of Business in Berkeley she is also a
co-founder of the pressure group
Economist for Ukraine in Australia it's
good to have you back on the show with
us this Friday energy sanctions on
Russia have backfired because they've
made energy more expensive and they've
boosted Russia's income despite lower
sales volume will this price cap will it
make a difference
so I think first we should be clear
about what it is that backfired and
that's the fact that the sanctions to
date have were implemented kind of slow
with a lot of deliberation right I think
you and I spoke about the price cap for
the first time in May we're now in
September
um and of course um what we what we
talked about back then is that
discussing measures like embargoes with
but taking a while to implement them can
actually drive up the price even before
the measures go into effect that's
exactly what we saw the highest oil
prices were actually in the beginning of
June right around the time of six
package that actually started to come
down
um since then so economically these
measures made sense back then that makes
sense now it makes sense to implement
them quickly and without wording that
has the biggest effect but of course
sanctions are not just about economics
they're also about politics and the
reason that these matters take some time
to implement is that we need to achieve
consensus so for the six package we need
the consensus within the EU and for the
price Capital that's a much more global
issue and so we need some measure of
consensus more blue and let's stick with
the economics for a moment on a global
level is this really going to bring down
inflation I mean it's not really clear
what the price will be and France has
said that it can't be implemented until
all of the EU states have agreed
yeah exactly
but let's be clear G7 agreeing to
implement a price gap on oil is not so
much about the purpose the purchases by
these G7 countries right it's not those
countries saying we're going to pay less
for Russia well those countries some of
them have already outright band Russian
oil some of them are phasing out Russia
well um within a matter of months so the
price cap is really about
kind of a global
um push to pay less for Russia as well
so we need consensus within the EU
um to use levers like shipping by
countries like Greece Cyprus um to use
levers like Insurance to use all of our
diplomatic
um means possible to coordinate this
price cap with third-party countries as
well and the level of the price Gap will
depend on that it will depend on our
bargaining power of the countries that
are looking to impose the price Gap um
with respect to the the rest of the
world then we've got a more neutral
third parties and how that bargaining
power compares to Russia's you I'm sure
you're aware that the U.S treasury
secretary Janet Yellen she has said that
Russia is going to have to sell at the
price capped by the West I mean is that
really true I'm thinking of these
third-party states that you mentioned
and can we quantify what effect this is
going to have on Russia's ability to
finance its war in Ukraine
yeah so I I think that um there's a lot
of reason to be optimistic about our
ability as the G7 as the EU um to have
this press cap actually be taken out by
Third parties as well and that's because
we have leverage we have leverage in
terms of
um shipping companies insurance
companies diplomatic means including
secondary sanctions um so as an example
uh last week Russia was offering
Indonesia a severely discounted
long-term contract um with a discount of
about 30 percent and Indonesia did not
take that offer sighting fears of being
under U.S kind of secondary sanctions as
the reason um so I think we definitely
have the potential and I view today's
announcement it's basically a signal
that we are reaching that consensus also
with um third-party partners and in that
case they can definitely have a large
effect on Russia's finances under
sociophatic with economists for Ukraine
Anastasia we appreciate your time and
your insights tonight thank you
thank you